rice krispies mac and cheese lasagna and
other comfort foods have never been more
popular
comfort food varies from person to
person but it usually involves
carbohydrates a dash of nostalgia and
basically what people crave when they
feel stressed
and in the midst of a global pandemic
economic downturn in a newly started war
americans have never been quite so
stressed
and these stressed adults have been
buying childhood treats and cooking
meals straight out of grandma's kitchen
big food aka the giant companies behind
oreos hot pockets meatloaf ice cream and
cheerios have been thriving as sales
skyrocket
at the same time food startups offering
innovation thrill of the new have
experienced some historic flame outs
it's difficult for emerging food brands
whose growth has been stunted by
packaging shortages rising
transportation costs expensive battles
over limited space on supermarket
shelves and investors have grown
progressively more unwilling to fund
innovation
at least 13 food companies went public
in 2021
and almost all of them have tanked
shares of beyond meat have lost 6
billion dollars since march 2020. at
vitacoco a healthier soft drink company
stock is down one quarter from its
october debut
app harvest a tech enabled greenhouse
grower of tomatoes and berries has
dropped 86 after the company reported
its first year results of nine million
dollars in revenue on a loss of more
than 160 million dollars
the stock prices of strive which
manufactures air-dried jerkies and xevia
which makes a stevia sweetened energy
drink have also fallen since going
public last year
for oatly a milk-like beverage made from
well oats revenue has risen 50
but investors aren't convinced
its market cap is down to 3 billion from
the 10 billion valuation of its july ipo
in short consumers don't want low carb
vegan mac and cheese
they just want velveeta
there's always hope however for new
tastes and culinary experiences
sometimes trends originate from the
strangest places
you